[MUSIC PLAYING]
You know, we talk a lot
about the nature of reality.
And we human beings,
we are a curious bunch.
We want to look up God's skirt.
And increasingly-- through
either our understanding
of quantum mechanics,
and all kinds
of new, exotic technologies
that are allowing
us to peer at the primary
building blocks of matter--
for whatever reason,
we're starting
to find some really weird stuff.
Buckminster Fuller
perhaps had it right
when he said, "God is a verb."
There's an amazing,
amazing article
by Kevin Kelly called "The Fifth
and Sixth Discontinuities,"
where he essentially talks about
a series of discontinuities
that have transformed the
context within which we
understand ourselves
in the world.
So we used to think
the Earth was flat.
We used to think the Earth was
the center of the universe.
We used to think all these
erroneous consensus realities
that we had agreed upon that
were smashed by science,
transforming the way we
understood ourselves.
We used to think
we were separate
from the other animals.
And then we realized that
we were descended from apes.
And then it just keeps
getting weirded and weirder.
Because now we're at the point
that through quantum physics,
through things like
nanotechnology, what we're
starting to understand is that
at the most primary level,
reality, matter
actually seems like it's
made up of information.
John Archibald Wheeler,
the quantum physicist,
used to say that
it comes from bit.
Bits, as in bits of
computer data, like data
comes before matter.
Description precedes "it"ness.
"The verbs are verbing
all by themselves,
without a need to
introduce nouns,"
I believe was the quote.
This idea that matter
acts, but there
are no actors acting
upon the action,
the verbs are verbing all
by themselves without a need
to introduce nouns.
Everything a signal,
everything is information.
Perhaps there lies the
mystery of consciousness.
But I just think it's
a fascinating idea.
[MUSIC PLAYING]